deepmind tackles fundamental mathematics
microsoft trains its most efficient and
effective language model yet and tim
nick gabriel launches her own research
institute welcome to ml news
look at this look at what i got as a
christmas present it is a
swag package from weights and vices so
so
[Music]
if you look there's there's lots of like
yellow fuzzy fuzzy stuff to package but
mainly
these are socks weights and vices themed
socks look at that it's weights and
vices socks they have like little bees
and little wands oh i get it
now you can see me here actually on
camera realizing the following see
weights and biases url is 1db.com
it's w and b now i have not realized
this before but the wand and the b
obviously stand for this url now you can
see me realize this right here on camera
watch it's one b like a wand and a b i
just got this right like literally i i
did not get this until right now
a wand and a b and then most importantly
this thing right here which is a
mug
excellent and this is really cool look
at that like it's a colorless logo it's
kind of imprinted in metal this is very
cool cup one sec all right i filled this
up with tea it is actually still
steaming it's completely hot on the
inside completely cool on the outside
excellent thank you very much weights
and biases for this awesome christmas
gift coincidentally this video is
sponsored by weights and biases if you
don't know weights and biases yet please
go check them out weights and biases is
the tool for your machine learning needs
it can do experiment tracking one line
of code tracks your experiments to the
cloud nicely viewable for every
experiment you can save all the output
all the logs all the graphs you can
compare experiments weights and biases
can track your data sets and your models
and save them as artifacts in the cloud
you'll know exactly how to reproduce
every single thing there is they have a
really neat feature called tables where
you can analyze your data filter it and
really go into the depth of where your
models still need improvement this is
not only useful during experimentation
it's actually useful all the way to
deployment and monitoring after you've
deployed your model and then lastly you
can also pull all of this into reports
which is an interactive document that
you can send to your boss your team
members your clients even and show them
interactively how their stuff is doing
reports are living documents with
interactive plots and tables and all of
the other features so if you still do ml
tooling by hand give weights advice is a
try it's completely free for personal
use and for academic use they have
solutions on cloud and on-premise
there's no excuse not to check them out
again thank you so much weights and
biases for sponsoring this video for the
awesome gift package as you see i am
very bribable and let's get into the
video
[Music]
deepmind has a new blog post called
exploring the beauty of pure mathematics
in novel ways and this blog post goes
along with a paper in the journal nature
called advancing mathematics by guiding
human intuition with a i this is a joint
effort by deep mind scholars and people
in the actual mathematical fields to use
ai to make new mathematical discoveries
now by new mathematical discoveries i
don't mean like the last digit of pi or
something like this these are actual
fundamental theorems in fields like
topology now because i'm pretty bad at
fundamental math right now i'm actually
going to speak to an outside
correspondent who gives us the details
on this story i'm speaking live to
marcus betting marcus it's very nice to
have you on the show hyonik thanks for
having me nice to be on the show in fact
i'm standing in front of the building
where math was once performed apparently
so marcus tell us has deep mind solved
math is ai doing math now are
mathematicians going to be obsolete
what's your take on that uh it's not
entirely that the algorithm does math
see what happens is that humans still
need to come up with some sort of
hypothesis that two quantities are
connected in some way but then the
machine is trained to learn a function
mapping from one quantity to the other
quantity and if the machine can do it
better than chance then that means that
there is some underlying pattern right
there but the machine can also not tell
the pattern explicitly but deepmind uses
various interpretability techniques
along with the results of the machine
and retraining the algorithm on
different subsets of features and all of
that is then given to a human
mathematician to make sense of so the
humans still need to come up with a
hypothesis of what could go together and
also the humans still need to interpret
the results of the algorithms to
formulate really a theorem and then
actually prove the theorem the algorithm
is only there to uncover new patterns
and then try to give various hints on
what these patterns could be that's very
interesting so what are the results of
this work what has been cheap so this
publication has actually resulted in not
one but two archive publications both
together with mathematicians in these
fields the first one is a new theorem in
topology establishing a connection
between the algebraic structure of knots
and the geometric structure of knots and
the second one is a new hint to sort of
a proof strategy for a long-standing
conjecture in representation theory so
does that mean that math could be solved
in the near future while these advances
seem impressive it tends to argue that
this only works really for a certain
subset of mathematical theorems namely
the ones where there is some sort of a
pattern between two numbers that we can
actually measure and the machine
learning model can make sense of
remember that mathematicians have used
computers for a number of years right
now to assist them and this is simply
one step more into that direction one
more class of theorems and hypotheses
that are amenable to now be done by
computers that help mathematicians but
it's not all of math yet and it's
arguable whether this approach will lead
to all of math being solved that is
fascinating thank you so much marcus we
appreciate your input very much thank
you very much for having me and uh good
day
microsoft research blog has a new entry
called efficiently and effectively
scaling up language model pre-training
for best language representation model
on glue and super glue the blog post is
about a new model in the microsoft
touring series called tnlrv5
this model gets state of the art on
super glue and glue which are famous nlp
benchmarks super glue and glue
themselves consists of subtasks where
the model has to solve different nlp
challenges the interesting thing is that
this progress hasn't been achieved by
simply scaling up the models like we've
seen until now but more so by actually
reducing the model's size a little bit
this model in fact says that it achieves
comparable effectiveness to other models
with fifty percent fewer parameters and
fewer computing cost in pre-training
it's pretty cool to see models going
away from the ever bigger ever more
paradigm into the paradigm of how can we
use the data and the compute that we
have the most efficiently so as you can
imagine it's not just a single idea that
comes to play in here lots of
interconnecting pieces are here mix of
scientific advances and engineering
advances they highlight a few things
such as the pre-training task where a
main transformer isn't necessarily fed
with original text and then trying to
reproduce that using language modeling
but it gets text that has been
pre-corrupted by an auxiliary model so
here you can see the auxiliary
transformer that gets a masked sequence
and is tasked to produce a sequence out
of that so sample a sequence of text
which is then input to the main
transformer and the main transformer's
job is not only to reproduce the text as
been input but to correct for the
sampling mistakes that the auxiliary
model introduced this is a bit more of
an intricate version of the classic
paradigm of the denoising autoencoder
that we've seen during training of bert
and so on and it seems that this task
makes these models more efficient and
effective with less data they also
highlight a few engineering features
such as customized cuda kernels for
mixed precision training and the zero
optimizer that allows models to be
trained on a massively parallel
architecture a cool feature of the model
is that it is not only more performant
if you scale it up but it keeps its high
performance even if you scale it down
which is different from other models
that only exhibit real power once you
either scale them up or keep them in the
low parameter regime what's also
interesting is how the model is going to
be released microsoft says here that
it's going to be released essentially as
an api in azure cognitive services so
that is a bit worrisome that we see more
and more especially big companies going
away from publishing their models
instead setting up apis mostly paid apis
or with some sort of other attachments
that lets them control their models
behind a wall and lets you only access
the outputs of it now sure these models
are a little bit too large to run or
train for most people but still i am not
sure if i'm a fan of this development on
the other hand it is welcome that there
are more and more competitors in this
market of offering large-scale models
via apis that means that a single player
like openai doesn't have necessarily a
monopoly anymore on inference on large
models if you want to know more of the
details of this model check out the blog
right here a link in the description
this is a cool website called the
nurip's anthology visualization it's
based on six years demo from henrik
strobelt and benjamin hoover from mit
ibm watson lab with data from lee
campbell tested by marc aurelio ranzato
i hope i got all the credentials right
here this is a website that
interactively maps papers that have been
submitted to nurips and accepted i guess
over the years since its existence now
not only does it map the papers and put
them into a low dimensional space it
also clusters different categories
together and highlights such clusters
for example there's this cluster on
papers on graphs and graph neural
networks there's a cluster in svms
there's a cluster on adversarial and
robust learning even one on neuroscience
now specifically the color coding is the
date or the year when these papers were
published and you can see a clear
evolution right here in fact as you
slide the timer here forward you can see
that the early papers were very much in
the realm of neuroscience and classical
neural networks slowly expanding into
deep learning svms and then an explosion
all over the place into bandits and
fairness and optimization and causal and
reinforcement learning while there were
always papers in all of these regions
it's definitely cool to see how the
conference and the entire field by that
matter has shifted from its origins into
the deep learning and general machine
learning world we see today it's also
cool to see that there are still quite a
few yellow dots in the neuroscience area
meaning that the true core of the
conference hasn't gone missing just kind
of buried under the thousands of papers
on gans and nerf what's also cool is
that you can select a certain area it'll
show you sort of a word cloud and papers
in that area as well as a graph over
time on how many papers were submitted
there and the coolest feature is that it
has a text field so you can enter your
abstract right here and localize your
paper in the whole map of new rips
submissions that's just the text field i
can enter whatever i want
i like to pick my nose calculating
position we're right here in the
classical neural networks uh
domain that is very true it is a classic
problem so let's see what our nearest
neighbors here are by drawing a shape
around we have papers like neural
network approach for three-dimensional
object recognition that is of course
very important like i have to recognize
in my nose in three dimensions if you
can see like in two dimensions i hit my
nose every time but in three dimensions
i completely miss it fast pruning is is
also very important because you don't
want to like pick forever you want to
kind of be done very quickly so this
site is definitely definitely worth it
if you're interested sort of in the
broader landscape of machine learning
research this is an excellent site there
is a blog post going with it that
details how exactly you can use the tool
and what features that if i haven't
actually shown you so far so definitely
check that out
[Music]
our next story timnit gabru launches her
own research institute the washington
post writes in this story google fired
its star ai researcher one year ago now
she's launching her own institute now if
i understand correctly the launching of
the new institute in fact comes exactly
one year after gabriel was fired from
google just for the record i think
google would claim that gabriel left in
this article there is a quote from
gabriel saying i've been frustrated for
a long time about the incentive
structures that we have in place and how
none of them seem to be appropriate for
the kind of work i want to do so now
she's launching her own institute the
institute is called d-a-i-r the
distributed ai research institute and
claims to be a space for independent
community-rooted ai research free from
big tech's pervasive influence for now
the institute is sponsored to a tune of
3.7 million us dollars from various
foundations gabriel herself also
published an opinion piece in the
guardian saying for truly ethical ai its
research must be independent from big
tech she again recounts stories of being
fired from google and seeing firsthand
the impacts that these technologies can
have and the power that the big tech
companies hold over it the research
institute's website states the way in
which they want to perform research they
say instead of constantly working to
mitigate the harms of ai research
performed by dominant groups without an
analysis of potential risks and harms we
encourage a research process that
analyzes its end goal and potential
risks and harms from the start the
research interests of the institute are
listed here developing ai for low
resource settings language technology
serving marginalized communities
coordinated social media activity data
related work and robustness testing and
documentation in one of the articles i
also saw a word about low resource
languages and as a speaker of swiss
german i fully approve we don't even
have a written form honestly i find this
to be a pretty good solution instead of
people that have problems with how big
tech conducts research just sort of
shooting against big tech and
complaining about it now they get the
opportunity to actually make research as
they see fit and if it turns out well
then it's i guess all the better now it
is a hard task to invent new things to
actually create new things while also
having all these things in mind that is
a pretty difficult problem that's why we
historically had people sort of pushing
technology ahead and then other people
cleaning up after them and sort of
making the already existing technology
better more accessible more fair and so
on this research institute's goals seem
to do all of these things jointly and
yeah i look forward to what comes out of
it and being funded through foundations
of course relieves some of the stress of
big tech which always has to essentially
make more and more profit the question
is of course a little bit what happens
when this money runs out what happens if
the sponsors themselves come and impose
some restrictions on the research
institute what if they want their
interests to be represented in the
research i guess even with foundation
money it doesn't come without any
strings attached it's not as easy as it
seems but it's different and i think
that's good
amazon announces sagemaker canvas which
is sort of a no code machine learning
platform on sagemaker as you can see
they have a few screenshots of the user
interface with interesting animated
characters you can import your data look
at it analyze it and then you can train
some machine learning models but here we
go we're doing some analytics on it we
train some classifier look we got a 99.9
estimated accuracy oh wow that is
amazing we can then analyze these models
that we've trained on various other
things and ultimately ship them out and
all of this without writing a single
line of code so no code seems to be a
calming business especially i guess
targeted towards people who might know
how to do a little bit of pandas but
might not be as versed in actual machine
learning and given that training simple
models has become quite an easy task to
do now it makes sense to integrate this
into a nice gui and make it accessible
to a lot more people
all right a quick series of helpful
things i guess this section was termed
helpful libraries at one point we'll
have to rename it you just like help
help like double help help help helpful
things and more mac birth is a series of
birth models pre-trained on historical
textual material the date ranges from
1450 to 1950. if you want some ye older
language you can find it in the hogging
face repository nvidia announces
tensorrt 8.2 which is a library that
makes machine learning models run faster
on nvidia hardware and the cool thing
about this release is the direct
integrations with tensorflow and pytorch
so rather than going through an arduous
process of converting your model from
your format to their format you can get
a lot of the speed ups already by a
single line of code for example they say
integration for pytorch delivers up to
6x performance versus in framework
inference on gpus with just one line of
code and the same goes for tensorflow
opecus released version 1.0 it is a
library to train pytorch models with
differential privacy now what i love is
how easy all these libraries make it
look like so you got your standard
neural net and optimizer and data loader
then you load up a privacy engine and
all you do is you say
make private and then they say now it's
business as usual seems pretty easy
whether or not that works out in
practice i don't know but if you're
looking into differential privacy this
seems like a very good point to start
this is clip guided collage which allows
you to give clip a bunch of these
individual elements in this case fruit
and then let clip generate a collage
from them i guess this is supposed to be
a smiley face at the end but there are
lots of cool examples all over i mean it
just looks really funky there is a
collab if you want to play around with
it and shout out to naotokui for
creating it thomas simonini writes we
just published snowball fight the first
hugging face deep reinforcement learning
environment so this is based on the
unity engine it's an rl environment but
it is in 3d and you can play it so i'll
be clem the duck and this is against an
agent that's been pre-trained with i
believe proximal policy optimization now
i have tried this before but it's not
that easy you get sort of this ouch
ouch
oh crap i died um yeah if you want to
try it out you can try it out on the
hogging face hub directly or you train
an rl agent for it archive sanity lite
is a new iteration of archive sanity
it's by andrei carpati and you have the
ability to self-host this system or
there is a version running online
archive sanity famously is a system
where you can enter your personal
preferences tags favorite papers and so
on and it will suggest you out of new
archive publications which ones you
might like most this is definitely a
good way to make sense out of the flood
of archive papers that come in every
single day if you liked my video about
backpropagating through discrete
blackbox algorithms you might also like
this related paper learning with
algorithmic supervision via continuous
relaxations this is a bit of a different
approach but it also allows you to work
with algorithms within the layers of
neural networks the videos by felix
peterson and a link to it in the
description coila is a library that
prevents cuda out of memory errors with
one single line of code so what you do
is you wrap your mini batches inside of
this library and the library will decide
itself how much to lazily compute
through the network so as you can see
all you have to do is you wrap your
input and label tensors in this lazy
function and off you go if you liked my
video about efficient xero the code for
it has now been open source check it out
shout out to cornelius md that won the
30 90 of our giveaway congratulations
cornelius and i'm sorry to everyone else
i hope we can make some giveaways in the
future as well looks quite pretty
doesn't it
and lastly there is an europe's blog
post called a retrospective on the
nurips 2021 ethics review process nurips
has ramped up its ethics review
including much more papers in the review
process recruiting much more reviewers
and this blog post is a reflection on
that process from the statistics you can
see that a couple of hundred papers like
two or three hundred papers were
ultimately flagged for ethic review
precisely it was uh 265 papers out of
9122 submissions one interesting fact is
that whenever two ethics reviewers were
assigned per paper and i think that was
the default they often didn't
necessarily agree whether or not there
were ethical issues with the paper they
give some of the examples here of the
identified issues lack of sufficient
reflection around topics that involve
thorny ethical considerations the use of
deprecated data sets that had been
explicitly removed by their authors lack
of transparency on model or data details
among other things a lack of
communications on the details of
annotator work conditions but also
things like violating copyright
restrictions and the lack of sending the
project through an institutional review
board in situations clearly involving
human subjects and lastly uncritically
emphasizing explicitly harmful
applications such as police profiling
they say in some cases the concerns
raised were so critical that the
acceptance of the paper was made
conditional on the authors implementing
the suggested mitigations all such cases
were discussed by the program chairs and
ethics review chairs and the ethics
reviewers were consulted in determining
conditions for acceptance of eight
papers conditionally accepted for
ethical reasons all were eventually
accepted they also say in a single case
the program chairs and ethics review
chairs jointly determined that the
required mitigations would be so
challenging to execute that they were
beyond the scope of what the authors
could realistically accomplish within
the time frame for the camera already in
this case the program chairs made the
call to reject the paper on ethical
grounds so ultimately one paper was
rejected and a bunch of papers were
forced to put something in that wasn't
originally in now what i find
interesting here is that again not even
the ethics reviewers necessarily agree
among themselves what is an ethical
issue and what is not which is a
consequence of there being much more
ethics reviewers this year i believe
than last year and therefore i guess
also a more diverse set of opinions now
this is both a good thing since i
believe more diverse opinions make the
field richer but also a little bit of a
bad thing as we now carry over the
absolutely noisy random review process
from the regular review over to the
ethics review where papers are hit by
yet another completely random or
semi-random process it's fair to say
that the same issues appear here when
you try to scale up these ethics reviews
as when you try to scale up the normal
reviews my other concern is that while
some of the ethics violations are
probably less controversial they're also
clearly political ethics violations
discussed right here and i'm not
entirely sure if that is a direction
that the field wants to go to take very
strong positions on things rather than
remaining neutral i guess it's not a
solved issue and the degree to which
this is important has to be figured out
by the community we'll see what happens
in the following years all right that
was already it for ml news thank you so
much for being here check out weights
and biases get enough sleep and i'll see
you next time bye
[Music]